le département des yvelines à nouveau
touché par une attaque terroriste
après l'assassinât de samuel pâtit le 16
octobre dernier le commissariat de
rambouillet a été visé par une attaque
vendredi 23 avril
la victime stéphanie mère de famille de
49 ans est adjointe administrative au
commissariat a reçu deux coups de
couteau mortel de son assaillant le
premier ministre jean castex s'est rendu
sur place accompagné du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin
il a exprimé son soutien à la famille
aux policiers et aux fonctionnaires du
commissariat de rambouillet je voudrais
dire à l'ensemble des françaises et des
français
combien notre détermination à lutter
contre le terrorisme sous toutes ses
formes est plus que jamais intact
l'auteur des faits de nationalité
tunisienne serait inconnu des services
de renseignement neutralisé par des
fonctionnaires de police il est décédé
sur place
le parquet national anti terroriste cci
de l'anc est pour l'heure les
investigations se poursuivent
cinq personnes ont été placées en garde
à vue de nouvelles précisions sur
l'attaqué ont été donné ce dimanche à
14h25
la victime faisait retour vers le
commissariat puis actionnait la sonnerie
afin de permettre l'ouverture de la
première porte du sas et pénétrait dans
ce nid si dans le même temps
djamel g après avoir récupéré son sac
posé au sol pourrait en direction de la
victime l'auteur des faits s'était
rapidement engouffré derrière la victime
lorsque celle ci avait pu franchir la
première porte du sas suite au drame
plusieurs élus locaux ont souhaité
s'exprimer on a voulu frapper là encore
un symbole de la france parce que nos
policiers sont la france ils sont le
visage de la france
et on a cherché aussi à déstabiliser le
pays en venant ici
s'attaquer aux forces de police dans
cette ville si tranquille du sud rural
de l'île de france et un quartier
tranquille c'est une ville tranquille
ce sont des fonctionnaires de police
qu'ils font leur métier de manière
absolument exemplaire au quotidien ils
savent que chaque jour potentiellement
ils peuvent mettre leur vie en jeu mais
là rien rien évidemment ne laissait
présager un tel drame pour une
fonctionnaire à une initative l'infamie
terroriste s'attaque de nouveau à notre
communauté nationale
lâchement en choisissant une symbolique
puissante une femme policière dans un
commissariat
c'est une nouvelle épreuve pour la
france et pour les français j'apprends
avec effroi l'assassinât d'une
fonctionnaire de police du commissariat
de rambouillet
cette ville qui m'est si chère une
victime de plus du terrorisme islamiste
je vais exprimer tout mon soutient la
famille de la victime ainsi qu'à ses
collègues policiers
encore une fois durement touchés plus
que jamais nous devons être à leurs
côtés
suite à ce drame la sécurité devant les
commissariats de police et les brigades
de gendarmerie va être renforcée